a new blockbuster movie revises history
the Weinstein scandal makes headlines
again and both parties endorse populism
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
oh man here adhere first before
President Trump tweets about it we will
get into the new movie biopic about Neil
Armstrong and the controversy springing
therefrom but first let's talk about the
economy so right now we could be in the
middle of a trade war or at least a
trade war could be launching obviously
we are putting tariffs on Chinese goods
the Chinese could be tariffs in our
goods they could start unloading our
bonds and things get bad enough that's
why you ought to be hedging against
inflation and hedging against
uncertainty and instability by
diversifying at least a little bit with
precious metals gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified in yours should be to the
company I trust with precious metal
purchases that's Birch gold group and
right now thanks to a little own IRS tax
law you can even move that IRA are
eligible 401 K into an IRA backed by
physical gold or silver it's perfect for
those who want to protect their
hard-earned retirement savings from any
future geopolitical uncertainty
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else gold safeguards
savings because it's never been more
zero Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau and right now contact
Birch gold group and you get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals this comprehensive 16 page kit
reveals how gold and silver can protect
your savings can legally move that IRA
or 401k out of stocks and bonds into a
precious metals IRA if that's something
you are interested in to get that
no-cost no-obligation kit head over to
birchgold.com slash Ben that's
birchgold.com / Ben they're the folks
that I trust with precious metals
investing birchgold.com / Ben we begin
today with a scandal that's not really a
scandal but is at least worth talking
about because it does say something
about the left's perspective and
hollywood's perspective on america it is
as they say one of the reasons President
Trump is president this particular
scandal comes courtesy of Damien
Chazelle now this makes me sad because
Damien Chazelle is one of the best
directors working today he did whiplash
and then he did lala land and his new
movie looks great it's a biopic titled
first man about Neil Armstrong who's the
first man to walk on moon and the stars
Ryan Gosling as Neil Armstrong but
there's one problem the movie apparently
omits the American flag why is that big
deal you say because at the most crucial
moment the picture that everyone cares
about from the actual moon landing is
Neil Armstrong racing the American flag
on the moon this is sort of like doing a
movie about the Battle of Iwo Jima
and not having the guys raise an
American flag instead they just decided
to raise an empty flagpole with like an
emoji sticker on it or something right
it makes no sense at all it's an iconic
moment in American history but Ryan
Gosling who is Canadian says that he
thinks that Neil Armstrong saw himself
more as a world citizen than as an
American hero which makes no sense at
all he says I think this was widely
regarded in the end as a human
achievement and that's how we chose to
view it well not by Americans it wasn't
not by Americans it turns out that when
America was putting a man on the moon in
China which is the real reason why
they're not putting the American flag in
this film is because they're afraid that
it'll piss off the Chinese censors and
they want to make sure that the Chinese
market goes to see the film so they've
removed the American flag it's the same
reason that long ago when they made
Superman Returns
they omitted truth justice in the
American Way they turn it into truth
justice and all that other stuff the
Hollywood is really really afraid of
taking off foreign audiences with all of
the America there's only one problem
with that logic which is that nobody in
foreign countries actually cares whether
American films promote America because
it turns out America's a pretty frickin
amazing place like we put a man on the
moon that's one of the pieces of proof
actually so Ryan Gosling Canadian says I
also think Neil was extremely humble as
were many of these astronauts and time
and time again he deferred the focus
from himself to the 400,000 people who
made the mission possible those 400,000
people would have been Americans by the
way who worked for the American
government he was running everyone that
he was just the tip of the iceberg
and that's not just to be humble that's
also true so I don't think Neil viewed
himself as an American hero for my
interviews with his family and people
that knew him it was quite the opposite
and we wanted the film to reflect Neil
alternatively Hollywood is just catering
to foreign audiences and so they're
going to omit the American flag in a
blatant attempt to grab Chinese money
but let's be clear putting a man on the
moon was an American mission it was not
a world mission it was an American
mission JFK who announced the original
missions put a man on the moon when he
did this when he talked about why we
would put a man on the moon he
explicitly linked it to America's
special rule in the world as a provider
of freedom remember this is the middle
of the Cold War and there was a lot of
talk in those days like right about this
time about the Russians putting a man
into space on the Sputnik satellite and
JFK decided okay we're gonna fight back
against that by actually going far
beyond that we'll put a man on the moon
putting an American flag on the moon was
the point of the endeavor it wasn't
ancillary to the endeavor it was
actually
point of the endeavor here's Jeff K
talking about the original mission we
choose to go to the moon in this decade
and do the other things not because they
are easy but because they are hard
because that goal will serve to organize
and measure the best of our energies and
skills okay and then he explicitly links
the mission to guess what the American
flag here's what he had to say about the
American flag in announcing this mission
he's talking about this at Rice
University's very famous speech
obviously well the eyes of the world now
look into space to the moon and to the
planets beyond and we have vowed that we
shall not see it governed by a hostile
flag of conquest but by a banner of
freedom and please so it turns out that
the American flag was sort of the point
right we didn't want the Russians to be
up there on the moon using it as a base
we didn't want the Chinese up there by
the way at the time that we were
actually throwing ticker-tape parades
for Neil Armstrong the Chinese were busy
stringing up people who were dissenting
from government policy so the fact that
we are now catering to a Chinese
government that remains a fascistic
dictatorship the fact that we are
catering to that government in order to
downplay the role of America it has a
lot to say with with the nature of free
markets free markets are not by nature
moral when it comes to who they take
into account markets are moral only in
the sense that they recognize that our
property is the fruit of our labor
that's what makes markets moral but
there's nothing that says a free market
is more when it comes to which audience
you are catering to and if Hollywood
feels you can cater to a Chinese market
by getting rid of American messaging it
will do so despite the immorality of
that basic idea but there's something
deeper happening here and that is that
Hollywood in the American left are
deeply embarrassed by the idea that
America is a nation that is a force for
good in the world
there's a hard core of the left that
believes that America historically it's
the Howard Zinn left believes that
America is historically a force for evil
in the world if you go listen to the
radicals over like chapo traphouse or
something another podcast on the Left
what you will see is that they're
constantly talking about historically
how America has been a force for tyranny
and fascism around the world and maybe
it would be better if America had just
backed off the world stage and allowed
the Soviets and the Communists to
dominate Africa dominate South America
it's all about America backing to your
it's the no I'm Chomsky view of history
and that is being indicated here every
good thing America did is actually a
whirl of achievement and every bad thing
America did is America's burden alone so
slavery was America's alone of putting a
man on the moon that was a world
achievement in reality it's sort of the
reverse slavery was a universal in human
history America fought a bloody war to
get rid of slavery that does not mean
that folks who engaged in slavery and
back slavery in the United States are
off the moral hook far from it but what
is uniquely American is not slavery that
was a universal world institution that
was also enacted in the United States
and was evil but what is uniquely
American is what we did after slavery
and the foundations of the country in
the Constitution there are certain
things that are unique about America the
left reverses all of these historical
truths everything that is bad about
America in reality the vast majority of
things that have been bad about America
were not unique to America they were
rather Universal and most of the things
that are good about America tend to be
pretty unique to America and not
universal which is why America's Rises
coincident with the greatest reduction
in world poverty in the history of
mankind why America's rise in terms of
economic power is coincident with the
dramatic decrease in child death in in
health problems even in pollution and in
the last 20 years America's been
reducing its own pollution by leaps and
bounds
the fact is America is a uniquely
wonderful place and the fact and and
because Hollywood doesn't choose to
recognize that they will remove any
indicator than anything good that was
ever done under American auspices was
done under the auspices of that American
flag they will champion people kneeling
for the American flag with regard to
isolated instances of police misconduct
but they won't put the American flag on
the moon it's more representative of the
American flag when there's a bad cop
than it is of the American flag when we
legitimately expend billions of dollars
to put a human being on the moon and put
the American flag up there that's
insanity but unfortunately that's a
pretty prevalent view among a lot of
folks on the radical left and I would
say even on the mainstream left now
meanwhile I think it's important to
point out some news regarding some of
the beloved candidates of the of the
Democratic Party and the left one of the
candidates who is rising fast in the
polls is beta O'Rourke beta O'Rourke is
running against Ted Cruz for the Senate
in Texas and the polls having him pretty
close I mean in spitting distance some
polls have them within the margin of
error Democrats are of course
extraordinarily excited about
that's if they could turn Texas blue if
then they'd never lose another election
I mean basically once Texas goes below
the country goes blue Texas is certainly
a bellwether state and what you saw in
the last election it was actually very
interesting is that while President
Trump turned Ohio red and he turned
Florida red and Wisconsin red and while
he turned Michigan red Texas was
trending more blue he actually he
actually won Texas by fewer points I
believe than Mitt Romney won Texas in
2012 I'm not mistaken
in any case bado Eric was expected to be
far behind Ted Cruz in the Texas race
turnout is gonna be very high on the
Democratic side and I think Cruz's camp
is is worried about our work in a way
that is pretty shocked and given the
fact that Texas is a deep red state it
is not a blue state in the proof is in
the pudding
Republicans dominate the state
legislature they dominate the governor's
office they have four years beta work
those being held up as the new face of
the Democratic Party should bethe own
work win the Senate seat in Texas
there's very little doubt that he would
be the frontrunner for the presidential
nomination in 2020 from the Democratic
side of the aisle he is a pretty good
speaker there they're trying to paint
him as a sort of Obama like figure that
he came out of nowhere and therefore he
is he is somebody who ought to be with a
formidable resume but apparently his
campaign has now run into a bit of a
speed bump the speed bump being that he
was involved in a DUI
20 years ago and actually apparently
tried to flee the scene of the crime
this is according to the Houston
Chronicle US Representative beta
O'Rourke has long owned up to his
drunken driving arrests 20 years ago
describing it in a Houston Chronicle
op-ed piece earlier this week as a
serious mistake for which there is no
excuse although the arrest has been
public knowledge
police reports of the September 1998
incident when the Democratic Senate
candidate had just turned 26 shows more
serious threat to public safety than has
previously been reported state and local
police reports obtained by the Chronicle
and Express news show work was driving
drunk and what a witness called a high
rate of speed in a 75 mile per hour zone
on Interstate 10 about a mile from the
New Mexico border he lost control and
hit a truck sending his car careening
across the center median into oncoming
lanes the witness who stopped at the
scene later told police that her work
had tried to drive away from the scene
so he's involved in a DUI allegedly a
DUI hit-and-run after crossing into
oncoming traffic
O'Rourke blew a 0.1 36 and 0.134 on
police breathalyzers which means that
bass
that he was made of alcohol at that
point that is not a mild drunk driving
arrest that is you have been drinking
incessantly for hours and then you get
in a car and rush into oncoming traffic
then try to flee the scene this is well
above the legal limit the legal limit in
Texas is point zero eight so he's
driving most twice the legal limit he's
arrested at the scene charged with DUI
completed a court approved diversion
program and had the charges dismissed
now listen as somebody who's had their
license suspended for speeding I've
never driven drunk I have had my license
suspended I would say that there is a
major difference between a speeding
ticket or even a DUI where you're pulled
over and you and you blow above the
legal limit and you rushing into
oncoming traffic hitting and hitting
other cars and then trying to flee
that's that's a significant amount worse
so bitter erupts candidacy could be in
trouble we'll talk about that plus
another Democratic candidate who could
be in trouble for even more insane
reasons in just one second first do you
feel like this year makes you want to
take a drink do you well listen I'm not
a proponent of alcoholism but you could
use a drink to relax every once in a
while and that's why you should go over
and subscribe to wink wink makes it easy
to discover great wine that's not just
for drinking in your home obviously
we're talking about you're going out to
dinner with somebody and you don't know
what a good wine tastes like you don't
know the difference between a bottle of
Manischewitz and a bottle of turpentine
you don't know the difference between
any of these things and so you actually
need a wine that goes with the meal
tastes really good but you don't know
anything so what you do is you go over
to wink wink swine experts select wines
match to your taste personalized for you
shipped right to your door starting just
13 bucks a bottle
there's nothing like coming home to a
box of delicious wink wine selected just
for you it's the best day of your month
just fill up that wink palate profile
quiz and they ask you simple questions
like how do you take your coffee how do
you feel about blueberries and then they
give you a wine that is specifically
tailored to your taste profile each
month there are new delicious wines they
have the insanely popular summer water
rose a that is flying off shelves right
now no membership fees skip any month
cancel anytime
discover great wine today go to try
winked calm /ban and get 20 bucks off
your first shipment that's t ry winc
comm slash Ben for $20 off again try
winked comm slash Ben folks around the
office of done taste tests of the wink
wine they love it they're less
productive that day but they're happier
go over and check it out try winked comm
slash Ben winc comm slash Ben for $20
off okay so beta or war could be in
trouble
in his Texas race to the great
consternation of Democrats that's not
even the craziest Democrat story of the
day the craziest Democrat story of the
day comes courtesy of
Senate candidate Julia Salazar so Julia
Salazar was running for the state Senate
in New York and she is according to city
and state New York she has attracted
significant often fawning media coverage
an army of enthusiastic volunteers
endorsements from politicians and
activist organizations and now withering
scrutiny a series of articles have dug
into her childhood religion and activist
history exposing facts that either
contradict or provide relevant context
to some of her biographical claims based
on interviews with her mother and
brother and Salazar herself city and
state has discovered additional
previously unreported instances of
Salazar falsely presenting her
background and others that are well not
technically untrue misleading but the
deeper one digs into the competing
narratives of Salazar's upbringing the
less it appears to be a simple matter of
truth or lies or he-said she-said
Salazar has told the few outright
falsehoods she claimed her family
emigrated from Colombia when in reality
she her brother and mother were born and
raised in the United States and her
father first came to the United States
as a teenager and was naturalized before
Salazar was ever born and she also
claimed that she had Jewish background
she has no Jewish background at all but
she's anti-israel she wanted to claim
that she was Jewish that she could get
away with the anti-israel nonsense she
also claimed that she grew up working
class in an economically stressed family
it turns out that is not true according
to her brother my family emigrated to
the u.s. from cologne so she said my
family immigrated to the u.s. from
Colombia when I was a baby my mom ended
up raising my brother and me as a single
mom without a college degree and from a
working-class background that's what she
told Jacobin magazine the socialist
magazine her brother says he remembers
them being financially comfortable
living in a big house along a river in
Jupiter Florida each of the siblings had
their own rooms the six-figure income
their father Luis Hernandez are owned as
a pilot meant the family could afford to
set aside college saving funds of about
$6,000 for each child he says we were
very much middle-class we had a house in
Jupiter along the river it was in a
beautiful neighborhood I feel very
strongly about my family and I want to
tell the truth so all of this is
basically a lie so that's pretty awesome
so that I like that every but she
recently said we didn't she she also
claimed that she didn't have permanent
residence in the United States that is
not true everyone in her family was a US
citizen because her father became a US
citizen sometime around 1984 so all
sorts of good stuff from Julia Salazar
and she is she's kind of a crazy person
it sounds like but the Democrats are
defending
because obviously she fulfills certain
intersectional boxes and that's of
course why they're defending bata or
work as well because those
intersectional boxes matter a lot more
than being qualified to actually be a
legislator in the United States the
Democrats are much more interested in
this sort of intersectional racial
politics than they are in anything else
and this is a broader trend in American
politics right now what's it's it's very
weird what's happening American politics
on the left you have people jumping into
a sort of left wing populism
that is wrapped around identity politics
so populism to describe what populism is
in sort of policy context is difficult
because populism is more a tactic than
it is natural policy populism is when
people say I speak for the people that's
populism when people say I speak for a
policy that's usually not populism but
if you had to sort of peg down the
populist attitude toward policy it's
usually distrust of major institutions
and so jamie curott puts it and i think
this is right distrust of major
institutions so sort of conspiracy
theorizing about the power of
institutions and in life belief that
your identity group is paramount and
distrust of the markets those would be
sort of the three big things you just
trust the free market because you think
the fruit the free market is rigged you
just trust institutions like the
government and you believe that your
identity group is paramount
well what's weird is that both left and
right have now embraced a lot of these
particular principles on the right this
manifest has anti-immigrant attitude at
a belief that we have to maintain you
know in quote-unquote white majority
there are parts of the right that have
actually argued this that the real
problem with with immigration is not
people immigrating from cultures that
may not be well assimilated in the
United States but it's actually the
countries that the people themselves
coming from countries that we don't like
right that's that's a bad attitude and
it's and that that's sort of right-wing
populism with regard to immigration on
the Left it's actually manifested as the
out-group is white Americans in many
case in the in-group is minority
citizens who have been put under the
thumb anti institutions on the right you
see this as everything that the the deep
state right everything the government
does is conspiratorial and an attempt to
get you and well I am on board with a
lot of suspicion of government
intervention ISM the economy I have real
doubts that the government is a
malevolent force in American life I
think it's much more to do with radical
incompetence and stupidity because most
people are radically incompetent and
stupid then it had
to do with conspiracy theories inside
the government and on the right the
anti-free market attitude which we'll
talk about in a second has taken the
form of big corporations are backing the
leftist agenda so we'll talk about all
those three from the right on the Left
these three attitudes manifest in a
different way so the in-group loyalty is
loyalty to this idea of a majority
minority country that that's very
important we have to push that and we
have to say that the future of America
is non-white you see this in an article
in The New York Times today the the anti
free markets attitude is evidence on the
left in virtually every respect and then
you have the distrust of institutions
which is America is systemically racist
America's institutionally biased and all
the rest and so there's this meeting of
the minds when it comes to distrust of
institutions distrust of the markets and
belief that the in-group is paramount so
let's talk about I think that the
populism of the right has in large part
been driven by the populism of the left
I think that a lot of the populism of
the right is a reactionary response to
the populism of the left particularly on
issues racial so I mentioned Julia
Salazar I mentioned also bata O'Rourke
obviously a lot of the enthusiasm for
Andrew Gilliam in Florida has to do with
the fact that he's black not just the
fact that he is a Democratic Socialist
by the way I mentioned quick correction
yesterday I suggested he was gay because
it's just a mistake he's not gay he has
a wife in any case the the
intersectional politics of the left is
very evident and the proof today comes
courtesy of the New York Times there are
two separate pieces in the New York
Times talking about the threat of
whiteness in America and why it would be
good if there was a white minority in
America there's the identity politics
populism of the left that has led them
to embrace a bunch of radical candidates
on their own side there's a piece by
Thomas Edsel talking about demography in
the United States and the fact that the
there are a lot of people he's very
against this he's there's a lot of
people who are Hispanic who now identify
as white now normally we would think
okay that maybe that's a fine thing like
how you self-identified racially that
maybe that's an indicator that you feel
comfortable in the United States if
there's this line that's being put out
by the by the press that America is a
whites-only country and that whites are
comfortable in America and then you
started self-identifying as well maybe
that isn't you being a race trader maybe
that's you basically saying I don't care
about my race anymore I'm just going to
identify as what the media would
identify me as because I'm successful
the reality is I think that our focus on
race in the country is
extraordinarily over-the-top in the most
tolerant in the first country in human
history but this article by Edsel in the
New York Times suggests that it's really
bad that people are self identifying as
white instead we should cuddle them back
into particular racial groups so that we
can have this majority minority America
and then identify voters by their
particular strain of race this is this
something Edsel is pushing over at the
New York Times that's not the only calm
there's a piece in The New York Times
today that's even worse which I'm gonna
get to in just a second but first let's
talk about your sleep quality so you
have a mattress is that mattress made
for you to just go to a mattress store
you lay on it for like ten seconds then
you bought it and now you're really
uncomfortable you're not sleeping all
that well this is why you instead I
ought to go to helix sleep calm or they
go tailor a mattress to you
helix sleep calm has a two-minute sleep
quiz and it will match you to a mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life for couples helix can even
split that mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they have
a ten-year warranty you get to try it
out for a hundred nights risk-free right
now helix is offering up to 125 bucks
off all the actress orders get up to 125
bucks off at helix sleep calm slash
bending and helix sleep calm slash man
for 125 bucks off your mattress order
their mattress are supremely comfortable
there are luxury mattresses at
non-monetary prices my wife and I took
the sleep quiz they sent us to the Box
we open it up and inflate it right in
front you it's good to go toss it on the
bed frame and it's great it's so good I
actually got a helix sleep mattress for
my sister for her wedding she loves it
as well go check it out right now helix
sleep calm slash Ben helix sleep calm
slash Ben for 125 bucks off your
mattress or to use that slash Ben so
that they know that we sent you okay so
the left populism on race takes the form
of identity politics there's a piece by
a person named Pankaj Mishra is a
contributing opinion writer focused on
ideas and politics of the neuro Times
the title is the religion of whiteness
becomes a suicide cult and the basic
idea is that everything she disagrees
with his whiteness everything she
doesn't like his whiteness because white
men are bad and whiteness is bad and
what would be better is if we were ruled
by an intersectional coalition of people
who have been victimized in the past by
American whiteness so this is what this
idiot writes putting Pankaj Mishra whose
representative of serious strain of
thought in the left-wing community white
men an obscure Australian academic named
Charles Henry Pearson predicted in his
eighth
93 book national life and character a
forecast would be elbowed and hustled
and perhaps even thrust aside by people
they had long regarded as their
inferiors black and yellow races China
in particular would be a major threat
Pearson prone to terrors of racial
extinction while living in a settler
colony in an Asian neighborhood thought
it was imperative to defend the last
part of the world in which the higher
races can live an increase freely for
the higher civilization his
prescriptions for racial self-defense
thunderously echoed around the white
Anglo sphere the community of men with
shared historical ties to Britain
Theodore Roosevelt who held a complacent
19th century faith buttress by racist
pseudoscience that non white people's
were hopelessly inferior reported to
Pearson the great effect of his book
among all our men here in Washington in
the years that followed politicians and
pundits in Britain and in settler
colonies of Australia Canada and the
United States will jointly forge an
identity geopolitics of the higher races
today it has written so you're saying
what is 1893 have to do with like 2018
it's 121 125 years later what is the why
well let let Pankaj Mishra explain today
this ideology has reached its final and
most desperate phase with existential
fears about endangered white power
feverishly circulating once again
between the core and the periphery of
the greatest modern Empire the
fundamentalists question of our time is
whether the West has the will to survive
president from said last year in a
speech hailed by the British journalist
Douglas Murray the Canadian columnist
mark Stein and the American editor rich
Lowry more recently mr. Trump tweeted
falsely about large-scale killing of
white farmers in South Africa a
preoccupy preoccupation deepened by
Rupert Murdoch's media of white
supremacists around the world so in
other words because Trump said that the
West may be losing its will to survive
that is an indicator of white supremacy
but the West is a unique thing in human
history and it is not because of race is
actually because of not caring about
race the West was shaped by a couple of
cultural forces judeo-christian values
and Greek reason none of them are
exclusive to race
I mean Augustine was was from North
Africa and the idea that that everybody
who is a part of Western civilization
was of one race even there were there
were legitimate racial battles between
like Italians and between the Irish and
the British it's only now that we
consider whiteness a thing and that is
largely yes due to racism of whites but
now it's being re kind of vivified by
this idea of
the left that whiteness is the
prevailing culturally dominant hierarchy
and we have to get rid of it and so in
this article this is the part that's
amazing this are this author basically
connects whiteness to every conservative
idea so if you're conservative this
means that you're an advocate of
whiteness which means that we need an
identity politics is left we need a
populist identity politics of the left
to fight the white over structure here's
what Mishra writes mr. Trump appeals to
some appears to some of these powerful
but insecure men as an able-bodied
defender of the higher races the Muslim
baiting British conservative politician
Boris Johnson says that he's
increasingly admiring of Donald Trump
mr. Murray the British journalist thinks
mr. Trump is reminding the West of what
is great about ourselves
the Canadian YouTube personality Jordan
Peterson claims that his loathing of
identity politics would have driven him
to vote for Trump so in other words all
of these guys are apparently white
supremacists because Trump is a white
supremacist and Trump was reading Teddy
Roosevelt I find all of this highly
doubtful but it's this identity politics
of the left that has has driven the left
into a populous area with regard to race
now they're obviously in a populist area
with regard to opposition to free
markets Bernie Sanders represents that
side of the party and then finally you
have the Democrats embracing this
distrust of institutions the idea that
all of our institutions are riddled with
corruption and evil and therefore must
be torn down from the inside this has
been matched on the right by the rise of
a sort of comparative populism this
looks a lot more like European politics
by the way the far-right politics in
Europe look a lot like what's happening
on the populist right here in the United
States which is big government but
distrust of big corporations anger at
immigrants and a belief that free
markets are corrupt inherently and and
we're starting to see that you know in
on the right and it's disquieting I
don't like it on the left it's really
ugly on the left and I think the
reactionary right is is doing some of
the same stuff as an example President
Trump yesterday was giving a speech in
which he was talking about the
quote-unquote old corrupt globalist
ruling class now remember President
Trump is the President of the United
States he is the head of a government
that has Republicans in charge of the
House and the Senate the executive
branch is incredibly powerful the
Supreme Court is largely stacked with
Republican appointees and yet here he is
railing against the idea of this old
corrupt globalist ruling class which is
the populist language of distrust of
institutions and free markets yeah this
sort of populism is is anti classical
liberalism it
when he says globalist ruling class I'm
not sure what he means he's very unclear
about this terminology but it
perpetuates this myth that people are
losing their jobs because there is a
cabal of people in power on the coast
who are attempting to remove jobs from
people in the middle of the country and
send them to China which is not actually
accurate free trade policy is not
responsible for the vast majority of job
loss in the United States free trade
policy is really involved with the vast
majority of growth in the United States
technological progress is what its
created job loss and manufacturing for
the most part because manufacturing
output is the same as it's ever been for
the last thirty years here's President
Trump going off on the old globalist
ruling class which sounds a lot like
Bernie Sanders frankly the so-called
resistance is mad because their ideas
have been rejected by the American
people they're the old and corrupt
globalist ruling class that squandered
trillions of dollars on foreign
adventures I mean that that foreign
adventures language that's that's like
Ron Paul Bernie Sanders stuff right the
idea that we're we've squandered money
on foreign we are still involved by the
way in a war in Afghanistan the
President of the United States has spent
an enormous amount of money on the
military as he should but this is this
populism of the right which is rising to
meet a populism of the left is not good
the best indicator of this last night
was Tucker Carlson who's a very into a
lot of this populist rhetoric now I
think Tucker's a really talented host I
think Tucker has a lot of intelligent
things to say but here he was yesterday
legitimately repeating Bernie Sanders
talking points to go after Amazon now
going after Amazon has become a
preoccupation since President Trump
decided particular corporations are
worth targeting Amazon is a fine
American corporation that provides
literally hundreds of thousands of jobs
across the country keeps other
businesses in business because you can
sell your product at via Amazon I've
never understood the attacks on Amazon
it doesn't make any sense to me Bernie
Sanders is attached on Amazon have been
that Amazon doesn't pay its workers
enough but the reality is the Amazon
pays the workers what they are willing
to accept because no one is being forced
into a job the chief reason that Amazon
like a lot of major corporations in the
United States doesn't pay very much to
its workers is because number one they
don't have to write supply meets demand
in the labor market as well and second
because the government provides an
enormous amount of aid in the form of
food stamps and welfare programs to
supplement the income that people are
from corporations like Amazon if you
actually want Amazon's pay rates to go
up all you have to do is remove a lot of
these government subsidies and then
Amazon will start paying higher wages
because no one can accept a job that is
not a quote unquote living wage you hear
this phrase a lot from the left a living
wage Amazon's not paying a living wage
what
by definition Amazon is paying a living
wage or you would be dead right any
lennie wage that you choose to accept is
by definition a living wage because if
you were dead you couldn't accept it or
if we're going to kill you you couldn't
accept it what you mean is that it's
wage you don't like but the worker likes
it enough to take it so here's Tucker
Carlson nonetheless using the same
populist rhetoric as Bernie Sanders
again not trusting free markets because
it's more important to distrust
institutions and therefore call for a
sort of bizarre centralized government
control it's certainly enough to pay his
employees well but he doesn't a huge
number of Amazon workers are so poorly
paid they qualify for federal welfare
benefits according to data from the
nonprofit group new food economy nearly
1 in 3 Amazon employees in Arizona for
example was on food stamps last year
Jeff Bezos isn't paying his workers
enough to eat so you made up the
difference with your tax dollars next
time you see Jeff Bezos make certain
diseases thank you ok it's actually the
opposite Jeff Bezos is not paying those
people because they aren't paying them
less because they're on welfare the
welfare exists and therefore he is
paying them less that's that's just the
way markets work again if there's a
subsidy more people are going to be on
that subsidy and you are subsidizing the
business on the other end the reason
that I bring all of this up really is
because I think that we're moving toward
a darker time in American politics or
certain basic principles of classical
liberalism are going by the wayside
there are inherent contradictions in the
populist ideology and philosophy these
inherent contradictions are pretty
simple let's say that you're an in-group
you trust the members of that in-group
that's an institutional in-group but you
don't trust institutions so why is it
you trust your in-group but you don't
trust institutions that doesn't make any
sense
you don't trust free markets but you
also don't trust the institutions that
are there to restrict the free market so
who do you trust
which is why populism basically ends up
being a lot of NP sloganeering
and fulmination about problems without
any real solutions but I guess that
entry fulminating has become the
culmination of our politics and then the
most irritating part is that we have
politicians who engage in this sort of
crap on a regular basis and then gloss
over it the minute that it rears
ugly head in a second I'm gonna talk
about that but first we're gonna have to
go over to Daily wire comm for $9.99 a
month you can subscribe to daily wire
that means get the rest of this show
live the rest of Clavin show live the
rest of Noel's show live and be part of
our mailbag today get your questions
answered right now when you subscribe
and write in live so go check that out
also you get the annual subscription
it's cheaper you get this as well the
leftist yours huh tour called tumblr you
will love it you will enjoy it you will
treasure it you will you when you are
buried when you die and you're buried
you will actually want this in your
coffin or alternatively you'll want your
ashes stored in it it's that great go
check it out the leftist here's patrick
old tumblr subscribe over at youtube or
itunes we have some pretty good stuff
coming up on the sunday special this
week it is Professor Edie fazer talking
about the logical and Aristotelian
proofs of God's existence so that's deep
stuff go check that out right now
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
when one of the as I say one of the
elements of deep irritation is that
populism because it is seductive
population here's the basic picture
populism is it's not your fault
that is the base of picture populism you
got a problem in your life well blame it
on the failure of markets or blame it on
the failure of institutions or blame it
on the out-group that is targeting your
in-group never blame it on yourself
never say maybe the problem in my life
is I live in a free country with a free
market with institutions that are
largely trustworthy and I'm just effing
up my life populism says it's not you
it's everybody else and so you see that
on the right and on the left and it
makes politics nastier because now you
have to in groups that see the out-group
as an enemy and that means that the
battles are going to become worse and
worse I was talking with my mom about
this last night with regard to the
Catholic Church because she was
suggested she was saying I don't
understand how it is that there are so
many people in various institutions that
are willing to go along with for example
the abuse of children just to protect
their institution and I was explaining
to her that human psychology is such
that we like to belong to groups when
these groups make us feel protected this
is the in-group mentality that is so
endemic to populism but it's also
endemic to the human condition if you're
part of a group you are safer if your
group is threatened you're going to rise
to the defense of the group and it does
not matter whether the group is
threatened for good reason or for bad
reason so if you read a child sex abuse
scandal as an attack on your group
rather than honest a good-hearted
attempt to cleanse the group of
something bad you are likely to respond
by defending your group even if it means
defending the bad thing and you're now
seeing this inside both political
parties as well you're seeing Democrats
respond to legitimate criticisms of
their policies ideas and politicians as
you're attacking my identity and my
identity group therefore you're evil and
I will fight you and I will try to shut
you down I will censor you and I will
use every method at my disposal to
silence you and then you see on the
right every time President Trump for
example does something that's actually
morally bereft people on the right say
well you're actually attacking my
in-group it's not that you're attacking
Trump I understand your real motive is
to destroy my end group and the problem
is that in both cases that's sort of
half right the right does want to
destroy the left in-group and the left
doesn't want to destroy the right hand
group the only way to get past this is
to get past the end groups themselves
and say listen I'm not interested in
destroying your in-group I don't like
your ideology but that's not a group
right your group the
groups that we're talking about that are
really dangerous are these identity
politics in groups the identity politics
of whiteness or a blackness or of
Hispanic Ness I think those are the in
groups that I'm not I'm not threatening
any of that stuff I see you as an
individual and your rip on president
Trump for stooping a porn star and then
paying off $130,000 that is not
necessarily an attempt to destroy
whiteness but I think that the radicals
in each group have an advantage once
people are engaged in a certain tribal
loyalty to their in-group radicals are
able to take advantage of that because
the more radical you are the more you're
threatened by the out-group which means
that your in-group comes to your defense
they say that again slower the more that
you are radical the more out groups have
reason to attack you but those attacks
the very presence of the attacks drives
the in-group to greater solidarity so
it's easy for radicals to take footholds
in in groups that feel threatened that's
a very very dangerous thing you're
seeing it happened with populism across
the country what's truly irritating is
some of the people who have been pushing
exactly the sort of populism exactly the
sort of in-group out-group division
those people now claiming that they had
nothing to do with it so for example Joe
Biden was being at John McCain's eulogy
yesterday and Vice President former Vice
President Biden who obviously wants to
run in 2020 says that he saw John McCain
as a unifying figure and he thinks that
we need to get past the attacks on each
other's motives what he says here is
correct and good and anti populist
there's only one problem
it was always appropriate to challenge
another senators judgment but never
appropriate to challenge their motive
when you challenge their motive it's
impossible to get to go but all we do
today
stop it they're weird because I seem to
recall Joe Biden saying this about Mitt
Romney's motives going back to the 2012
campaign I campaigned by the way that I
think broke the country I think 2012 is
really the moment that the country
I think fragments it maybe beyond
recognition here was Joe Biden driving
this leftist populism of identity
politics that has crafted that has
driven the reaction and led to a
populist rise out on all sides look at
their budget and what they're proposing
Romney wants to let that he said the
first hundred days he's gonna let the
big banks once again write their own
rules unchain Wall Street
you're gonna put y'all back in Chains
you speaking at a historically black
church and historically black church she
was saying the Mitt Romney is gonna put
y'all back in Chains but don't worry he
wasn't questioning anybody's motives Joe
Biden also likened the Tea Party to
terrorists back during that campaign in
2000 in 2011 actually he said that and
even going all the way back to 2008 when
he was running against John McCain right
he was on the VP side running with
Barack Obama against John McCain he said
that it was unpatriotic not to back his
tax program we want to take money and
put it back in the pocket of
middle-class people anybody making over
250,000 dollars he's gonna pay me god
it's time to be patriotic okay time to
jump in time to be part of the deal if
you don't have his program you're not a
patriot right so all these people who
are engaging in this exact sort of
populist political rhetoric now they
turn around they say they don't like it
when Trump does it they were the
creators of it so let's be clear where
all of this came from and let's also be
clear that standing for a certain moral
standard when it comes to classical
liberalism and politics is actually an
important thing there are central
principles in American politics and
those principles do include seeing
ourselves seeing America as the big end
group and unified by principle and
seeing free markets as a good thing and
seeing our institutions as bedrock of
American honesty Yalie we're were
spoiled in this country really are when
it comes to the honesty of our
institutions we like to talk about the
corruption of American institutions yes
there are certain institutions that have
corruption embedded in them there are
certain there are certain individuals
who are corrupt but try another country
and see how corrupted is where you're
actually paying off police officers to
get your business done I mean the idea
that of America's great virtues of the
fact that our institutions are
historically non-corrupt actually okay
so let's get into some mailbag let's get
into some mailbag so here we go
Stephen asks does your wife brag at her
work about her husband the lawyer
because obviously I bragged a lot about
my wife the doctor no after my wife
tends to keep what I do on the DL on the
down-low because there's a lot of
blowback in every institution in
California if people know that you're a
conservative there have been a few cases
where patients have gone in and see my
wife and known who she was and she
always finds that hilarious and
flattering but like a lot of her
co-workers don't know what I do for a
which is pretty hilarious Rachel's has
been what do you think of space force
why not just add the duties to the Air
Force I'm not sure why you wouldn't have
the duties to the Air Force I'm not
enough a military expert to know the
answer to that question but I do like
the idea that we ought to have some sort
of military understanding of space
because that is a space that we are
going to have to protect obviously there
are foreign nations that are attempting
to militarized space
melissa's hey Ben my relationship for
four years just ended the main Ravin
reason given was that my now ex didn't
want to marry me or possibly ever get
married if it meant that there would be
times of struggle in the relationship he
comes from a broken home with a sort of
Elizabeth Taylor story on one side my
parents have been married for 34 years
so I've watched them work through all
the tough times and come out stronger as
someone who has what appears to be a
strong marriage what is your advice to a
millennial looking to find a future
spouse willing to build a life together
including overcoming adversity all the
best Melissa well honestly this is an
entry level question that you need to be
asking the person you're dating now you
shouldn't find out four years into the
relationship that the person doesn't
want difficulties in the relationship
and doesn't want marriage like you
should be dating for marriage that is
the only in my view this is the only
purpose to date I really I do not
understand the idea of dating to live
together I don't understand the idea of
dating for sex it doesn't make any sense
to me the entire purpose of dating for
marriage of dating should be that you
want to create a long lasting
relationship with ended within which to
build a family and that means asking
tough questions I'm like the first eight
and by the way as soon as you date with
direction in mind your dating life is
going to change because you're actually
going to be able to dismiss people who
are waste of your time you're not going
to be wasting time with losers who latch
on to you for four years and then decide
they don't want to get married and
ladies you're not going to draw a man in
by living with him that's not how this
works maybe the old saw they no one buys
the cow vein get the milk for free there
is a there's a large grain of truth to
that you know what you know what kind of
women men want to marry the kind of
women who make it clear that they want
to be married if men can get away with
not marrying women then they will do it
because that's how men are if you want
to get married make clear to the dude
you're not doing anything until you get
married and he will marry you really
there's an entry-level there's in any in
any relationship whether it is business
or whether it is personal in order for
somebody to fully commit to a business
relationship they have to have skin in
the game the only way to get skin in the
game when it comes to actual marriage is
to
to say you are not going to get anything
out of me basically and I mean in terms
of sex particularly until marriage
actually happens I think that virginity
until marriage is not just a good idea
for your own protection I think and for
your spiritual good I think it's
actually a pretty good negotiating
tactic is the reality so do what you
want it's free country but if you want
my advice on how to actually snag the
kind of person worth marrying make clear
to the person that that's what you're
looking for because it draws a different
kind of person every job has a job
description the job description of
husband is not the same as the job
description of a guy I want to live with
for four years and then get dumped by
Veronica says what do we do about
religious people who reject conservative
politics like being pro socialism
because they don't understand that
charity isn't the government job well
again I think the number of people who
truly believe that religion dictates
socialism is very low I think there are
a lot of socialists who like to use
religion as a guise but this sort of
progressive social justice religious
folks very often these are the same
people who suggest that the Bible is
fine with abortion so I have a very time
tough time believing the the sincerity
of those particular motives and I say I
don't like questioning people's motives
but when the motive clearly does not
line up with the purported motive I have
a tough time understanding where exactly
the gap takes place that said you know
there there are lots of it does say in
the New Testament that who he who does
not work nor shall he eat the the the
New Testament focused on sharing and
common among us which is one that the
left likes to use a lot is specifically
talking about the disciples who are
being treated more as a family
there is something worth noting when it
comes to religious talk about the
quote/unquote sharing among people
religious communities were designed to
build out family to larger levels that's
basically the idea you're a socialist
I'm a communist in my own family right
from each according to his ability to
each according to her need when it comes
to my daughter right that's the way it
works inside families that's not the way
that works in society at large and
trying to apply the rules of religious
redistribution ISM in a communal context
to a broader society that that compels
redistribution ISM is actually a form of
theocracy so all these all these sjw's
who are quoting the Bible asked them
whether they're for theocracy because
it's kind of weird Bobby says hey Ben my
son was finally born my question is
considering to let classical do also
like the Opera if so what were your top
five operas be can't wait see you in
Pittsburgh this November thanks
so I do really enjoy opera bezees Carmen
on the Magic Flute by Mozart though
those would be the top two I'm trying to
think what else
La Boheme the let's see there there's so
much good opera hmm I actually have to
think about this one there's some verde
there's some Poochyena that's really
really good stuff
I do like Fidelio which is an underrated
opera by Beethoven and but but basically
everything by Mozart is just in town
Giovanni Don Giovanni sound Giovanni
obviously that's a huge how could I
forget to on Giovanni my favorite
actually evolved them Jay says all
husbands in white fight from time to
time
how do your fights go with your wife and
have you ever told her facts don't care
about your feelings so I did actually I
have ripped off a meme that somebody
made about me and fights with my wife
whenever my wife my wife does what all
women do which is she gets dressed and
she puts on makeup and she looks very
pretty and then she says do you like
this outfit and I say yes I think you
look beautiful which is why I don't feel
beautiful and then I say impacts don't
care about your feelings right so that's
I have actually used that line before um
but as far as fights with my wife we
don't typically tend to fight I mean
really we don't fight a lot when we do
disagree I think that I've tried to
develop over the years the capacity to
understand where my own upset is coming
from is it coming from her being
unreasonable or is it coming from me
being unreasonable or glomming on too
hard to my own emotional state because
sometimes you're just stuck in an
emotional state now you're gonna lash
out about it you know I've very often
fights come because you bottle stuff up
for a long time but there are a few key
things I think in fights number one
never say always are never when you say
always remember it's always inaccurate
okay there there that's the one time you
can use always so when you say to your
spouse who you always do X it's a it's a
recipe for failure because your spouse
doesn't always do X your spouse
sometimes does X and it drives you nuts
right your spouse does something
sometimes to drive you nuts but it's
important to recognize that that
sometimes is not always also I would say
that most of the major fights that
you're going to have most of the major
character flaws are gonna have get them
settled while you're young because by
the time you hit 65 you're set in your
ways and it's very difficult to change
and you see this with with people who
are above the age of 60 and I think that
it's important to you know try and iron
all that stuff out
as fast as possible that said why do I
fight with my wife sometimes yeah my
wife and I had had a bit of a tiff on
Sunday it was actually really really
funny it ended up being really funny so
basically here's the story and she's
gonna be so pissed I'm gonna tell this
on air so here's the story so my wife
was really really tired she'd been tired
because she'd be working the previous
night and we had to go to this bat
mitzvah that you know I didn't know
people but she knew the people and so we
had to know this bat mitzvah on a Sunday
night and my wife has my pet peeve with
my wife he's really simple and stupid
one she loses her phone all the time
like legitimately she's lose it all the
time and when she loses her phone she
doesn't say to me she does she doesn't
look for it for 10 minutes and then say
I've lost my phone she immediately says
I've lost my phone which makes me feel
like she's losing it even when she's not
because she'll say I've lost my phone
then five seconds later she looked down
and it's right there right so in any
case we're about to leave and we have
both our kids in the house and my
parents are taking care of the kids and
my wife turns to me she says I don't
have my phone and I say well is that a
big deal like I've got my phone my
parents can call me it's not really a
big deal she said well I feel more
comfortable to my phone I said okay why
don't you just go back in the house and
get it we're sitting right outside the
house and she says I'm too tired can you
get it I said you know okay fine I'm
already late to this party okay okay
fine and you know I'm not I'm not happy
about it my son right now is very
attached to me so if I walk back in the
house
we both sneaked out of the house so he
doesn't make a fuss if we walk back in
the house my son is going to jump on me
like a barnacle on a whale or this is
what he does he's two-and-a-half he just
runs to me and he grabs my leg and won't
let go and it's very cute when you're
trying to leave and then he breaks down
into a crying fit it's not quite as cute
so I say you know it would be better if
you went inside because he's not gonna
bother you as much it's not I'm really
tired I just I don't care enough I don't
care enough let's just go I said well
now you've got me right because you've
just said you didn't you want the phone
and you don't want to go and now you're
telling me that you don't care and let's
go so fine I'll go inside I'll go look
for the phone so I go inside I have no
idea where the damn phone is well how
would I know where the phone is I don't
know where she's been in the house so
I'm searching around the house and sure
enough like a shot out comes my son
running to me and grabbing my leg and
screaming so I pick him up I'm walking
around the house I look around for five
minutes I can't find it we're even later
to this party I walk out - I finally
kind of pushed my son off to my dad and
I start to walk out of the house and I
walk back to the car and then
my and then my son comes charging out
the front door after me and I walk back
to the I said sweetheart I don't know
your phone is can you get up off your
butt and go in the house and look for
your phone you know where your phone is
right like you know where it is or at
least you have a better idea cuz you
know you worry where the hostage is no
no I don't know no I'm not gonna you
know I don't need it it's not important
and so well now you've made me go in the
house and bring my sons running after me
and I'm gonna have to go back in the
house now and by this point I'm ticked
and I said I'm gonna go back in the
house mm-hmm and I said I'll go back in
the house I look some more can't find
the phone right I finally come out I say
sweetheart you're being really really
unreasonable this is not reasonable and
she says well I don't care anymore let's
just go so she consents I am
extraordinarily post because I'm very
angry at this point and when I go angry
I tend to go silent rather than yelling
I'm not a Yeller
so I go silent and we drive for about
three minutes and now the car is on and
because we're driving and then strangely
a phone begins to ring in the car
through the speakers of the car and
we've tried calling her phone before we
got nothing it turns out that it's
ringing in the car because even when
your phone is on silent it rings through
the car speakers right but the car
wasn't on when she was sitting in it
where was the phone the entire time they
need her bud so if she had just gotten
up for ten seconds she would have seen
that the phone was right there and we
would not have had to do any of this it
was my dad calling just to tell me that
the kids were fine and I said dad if I
come home in the car by myself it's
because I tossed my wife's body in a
lake and and you know don't tell the
cops we both started laughing because
sometimes is something out of a sitcom
so that's that's typically how our
fights kind of go they usually end with
us laughing about most of them but my I
will say my wife is an incredibly
understanding and giving person and so
when I have critiques of her she takes
them really well and I've tried to do
the same and it means that our fights
become us fights and more discussions
about how we can improve in the future
which is the best way to handle things
and it has to be less accusatory for
fights has to be less accusing and a lot
more sort of you know here's how we can
fix the problem it has two fights have
to be proud to be problem-solving
oriented they have to start off as
understanding Orient's and then move to
problem solving they can't start off as
problem solving and then move to
understanding because if you start off
with I want to solve this problem the
other person doesn't feel understood
that's a hard one for me okay let's see
let's see
girl says what are your thoughts on the
operating paradigms for media bias
should members of the media be
transparent with their personal biases
and operate along the lines of their
biases or should members of the media
always seek to be central line in their
coverage perhaps there's a difference
between an ideal and practical approach
so I think that we should know how
everyone feels politically and then we
can take it with a grain of salt and you
can say listen I'm a conservative but
I'm trying to cover this story straight
right I do this on the show all the time
actually I say I say all the time on the
show I'm a conservative but I'm gonna
try and be as objective as possible on
this story you can take my objectivity
with a grain of salt but at least I'm
gonna try and separate my opinion out
that seems to me the honest way to do
things being completely transparent is
the best way okay final one mark says
hey man I'm addicted to all things ben
shapiro the first thing i do when my
feet hit the floor every day is check
daily wire that question is what sites
do you check what are your first couple
of go-to sites when you start your day
thanks your biggest fan Mary please come
to Tampa soon so my honestly I'm a
Twitter guy obviously I'm on Twitter all
the time one of the reasons I tweet so
often is because it's also where I get
my news a lot of my retweets the reason
I retweet so often is to remind myself
of stuff that I want to talk about or
write about a little bit later in the
day twitter is still the central source
of news so I think that's that's
something worth noting okay you know
what I lied one more sorry guys here it
is
oh there's so many good questions today
and I'm so mad Jacob says hey Ben my
name is Jacob okay I'm a 19 year old
college student I'm also a proud third
degree member of the Knights of Columbus
and a proud Catholic with the recent
news of the scandals inside the Vatican
a lot of hate for my church has come to
light it pains me to hear people talk
like this about my faith as a very
religious person and since people of the
Jewish faith are no strangers to hate
you have any advice on how to deal with
it Thank You Jacob well I think you have
to determine what the cause of the
hatred is very often people are using
the hatred of a particular incident or
thing as an excuse for hatred of the
church generally you see the sedan's
high Semitism all the time it's like
they just people hate the Jews and they
just find some sort of hook to latch on
so people hate the Jews because all the
Jews are communists no people hate the
Jews because all the Jews are capitalist
pigs no
people hate the Jews because of the
State of Israel no people hate the Jews
because there are rootless nation less
people the same thing happens with
regard to any out group if you hate the
out group you can find an excuse to hate
the out group and trying to identify
whether this is an honest critique of
the in-group is a worthwhile endeavor
you try to determine from from where all
of this is coming okay
you know I lied again this is it's a
good question so this is I promise this
is the actual last one and we'll do a
very short things I like in things I
hate just to just to round it up Gregory
says dear supreme overlord Shapiro
recently I got into a debate with one of
my good friends over the definition of
racism my friend contends that according
to people with PhDs who study the issue
true racism is when the race that holds
power or privilege in a society uses
that power or privilege to suppress
other people of other races now a friend
went on to say because of white
privilege it is only possible for white
people to be racist I found my friends
definition of racism to be very
disturbing because I personally believe
racism is something that occurs anytime
someone is treated unfairly solely based
on the color of their skin I do not
believe power or privilege in society
plays any role in determining what is
deemed racist I'd like to get your
opinion well I totally agree with you
now does that mean that all racism is
inherently equally dangerous of course
not
racism combined with power is a lot more
dangerous than racism combined with non
power but racism is itself is a toxic
brew and even if you are victimized and
you engage in racism what you are doing
is poisoning your kids and you never
know in a free country and even in non
free societies which race is gonna end
up on top again right this is the
problem with the argument that racism is
inherently connected to power well so if
a group let's take some Bob way for
example whites were racist against
Blacks in Zimbabwe clearly clearly hey
now let's say that that's and into
blacks many blacks were racist against
whites and Zimbabwe was that a good
thing was that an okay thing
well maybe the argument would go they
didn't have any power so they couldn't
actually be racist but then it turns out
that black folks took power in Zimbabwe
and then that regime has now reduced
farmers white farmers in Zimbabwe to
almost a subject state by seizing their
land is that what we did only become
racism when they gain power or is it
just that racism itself is something
toxic evil and and terrible and it is
made a lot worse in terms of real-world
effect by power it's not that it's not
that racial hatred plus power equals
racism it's that racial hatred equals
racism racism plus power equals
something a lot more dangerous and it's
the easiest way to explain it okay time
for things I like and then things I hate
so the thing I like today is a book
called the diversity delusion by Heather
McDonald we're gonna have Heather
McDonald on the Sunday special at some
point in the future it's a really really
good book it's all about the subtitle is
how race and gender pandering corrupt
the University and undermine
culture our colleges have become
repository of leftist thought that
leftist thought has led to exactly the
sort of identity politics populism we
are seeing right now and the exactly the
sort of rise of democratic socialism and
hatred of Central American principles
we've seen Heather McDonald details all
of the nuttiness going on in our
university level with Letran intimately
familiar go check out the diversity
delusion by Heather McDonald who full
disclosure I'm friends with and we
became friends because I like her
writing so much so go check it out
Heather McDonald the diversity delusion
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
Stephen a Smith said something dumb on
ESPN because today ending and why and he
was talking about Serena Williams and he
said about Serena Williams that if she
were a man we would call her the
greatest ever you just say that if she
were a man what would we be saying we'd
be calling her the greatest ever there
would be no dispute we wouldn't even be
talking about Michael Jordan and that we
would have be talking about Mohammed Ali
we would be talking about Serena
Williams because of the sustained level
of greatness and I think the only reason
we haven't is because she's a woman well
no the reason that we haven't is because
I mean I guess so in that she would lose
to the two hundredth ranked men's player
so there's that we can say she's the
greatest woman ever if he really
believes that she that it's only there's
only sexism that prevents us from
calling her the greatest ever then why
don't we just have open brackets at the
US Open really we just do that like no
sex no sex discrimination at all we'll
just have men and women compete in the
same brackets and then we'll see if she
is indeed at the greatest ever or if
she's the greatest woman I don't see
what's wrong by the way with being the
greatest woman ever like what's so bad
about this why is that so terrible
it doesn't why can't we just acknowledge
that men are more physically powerful
than women on average and also far more
physically powerful at the upper end of
the bell curve why is this it why is
this so difficult
it's because everything is stupid
somebody tweeted out today there's a big
story about income disparity when it
comes to tennis when a complex sport
said Venus Williams demanded equal pay
for women before Steph Curry was even in
college and then it says total earnings
highest-paid male tennis player Roger
Federer seventy seven point two million
dollars highest paid female tennis
player Serena Williams eighteen point 1
million dollars you know why because far
more people care about men's tennis they
care about women's tennis the ratings
are fire far higher for men's tennis the
players are far better in men's tennis
the players are more popular
in men's tennis I mean this is like
saying well you know the pay in the NBA
is just orders of magnitude larger than
the WNBA right because no one in history
has ever wanted to see the WNBA for
basketball reasons no one right people
want to see the a WNBA for political
reasons or for gender parity reasons or
to show their daughters that girls can
play basketball too oh that's fine but
if you're looking for a display of
physical athleticism and skill you're
not actually going to want to watch the
WNBA WNBA championship teams could be
beat by the leading high school teams
men's high school teams boys high school
teams in America the Women's World Cup
soccer team there's the story that came
out when they won the World Cup and I
think 2000 something like that they
played like a good high school or good
college soccer men's soccer team in
Australia and lost six nothing something
again none of this is to suggest that
women can't be great at sports they're
held a lot better than I am I mean I
wouldn't get on the court with serene
wheelers you blow me away obviously but
if we are going to be honest about
discrepancies and disparities we can't
attribute them all to discrimination
otherwise we are just being idiots okay
we will be back here next week have
yourself a wonderful Labor Day weekend
enjoy it come back refreshed on Tuesday
I'm sure the world will have imploded in
some fashion and we'll talk about all of
it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing